welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
what if episode 8 what if ultron won a
truly terrifying age of ultron that even
the watcher and his fighting pjs can't
stop this episode was filled with
interesting easter eggs and mcu
implications so i'm gonna break it down
frame by frame for everything you might
have missed we open on the watcher his
outline framed in the snow of
post-apocalyptic moscow unlike past
appearances his silhouette has retreated
behind the elements of our atmosphere
reflecting how powerless he now seems
this episode with the falling snow like
pieces of himself as he risks
dematerializing into obsolescence he
laments we've seen this before a
universe in the final days of
destruction
but this
particular story
this
this one breaks my heart i'm curious
about the exact timing of the watchers
narration by we've seen this before he
seems to be referring to past
apocalyptic episodes he's shown us like
the doctor strange and the zombies
episodes but it's not clear if this
watcher was the one who reacted to
ultron's arrival to party thor in
episode vii so is the story that breaks
his heart the story of ultron's
destruction of earth that we're about to
see and he's now speaking to us right
before the moment ultron sensed him or
are we seeing a truly defeated watcher
speaking to us as a ghost beyond his
cosmic grave and his heartbreak is
really coming from the story of what
ultron is about to do to the multiverse
in the second half of this two-part
finale event is this evidence of
multiple watchers i have some thoughts
on this later but here natasha romanov
roars passed on a motorcycle her
taillight bleeding a streak of red like
blood in the water luring some predators
in this case ultron sentries meanwhile
clint barton's arm was replaced with one
from an ultron sentry showing how in
this machine-dominated post-apocalyptic
world he must supplant his flesh with
pieces of that which he hates but it's
worth noting that this is now the arm in
hand that clint uses to release his
arrows so he does benefit from the
technological precision of those robotic
motor functions clint's cloak is made
from the same mesh fabric that natasha
and melina and sharon carter have used
for cloaking purposes clint does rely
mostly on his century arm to do the
heavy lifting but as he fires a hole
through one of their heads notice how
the camera frames his human hand through
the kill hole a way of showing triumph
of man over machine and natasha helps
clint to his feet avoiding joking need a
hand claiming puns aren't her style yet
notice the next line puns aren't really
my style
we're getting rusty
getting rusty as in clint's mechanical
arm collecting rust yeah she loves puns
then the watcher rewinds the clock to
tony's invention of ultron i see a suit
of armor around the world a direct quote
from age of ultron i see a suit of armor
around the world back then tony designed
ultron to operate his iron legion an
idea he pitched to bruce banner and i
love how in that conversation it
inspired this what if hypothetical given
the little exchange between them in that
moment that's a man-sized if
our job is if ultron goes online and in
this moment he's weirdly already in his
later form not the disembodied ai he was
born as in the film and then shortly
after the broken iron legion drone
actually that was the same one that the
scovian protester defaced in the opening
scene of the movie but then this ultron
cross dissolves into the body that would
later become vision resting in the
cradle in helen shows south korean
facility this transition neatly shows
how ultron successfully merges with the
vision body this time instead of helen
cho pausing the upload at 42 in the film
and notice how when he opens his eyes
they glow ultron red the color that
shows his consciousness in any given
century drone contrasting vision's blue
eyes but remember helen show is only
able to stop that upload when wanda max
moff dispelled her from the mind stones
mind control it's just worth noting how
many of these nexus moments really come
down to the decisions of wanda maximoff
or steven strange who will be the
pivotal characters in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness and speaking
of nexus the avengers defeat by ultron
goes down in the nexus internet hub in
oslo norway seen briefly in age of
ultron when tony stark tried to track
ultron's movement through the internet
and is this is the center of everything
i'm just a guy looking for a needle in
the world's biggest haystack oh
i'm decrypting nuclear codes and you
don't want me to aha so ultron ascends
on its path toward becoming a nexus
being at the nexus internet hub now
theoretically ultron's assimilation
would have occurred right as tony made
that crack about the nuclear codes which
could have actually led ultron to this
place to initiate global nuclear
annihilation which is way more fun to
wipe out the human race than throwing a
chunk of a city back at the surface you
don't have to do this i made you for
peace it's evolution only a primitive
mind would fail to see the distinction
which is why you have to die now
replacing james spader as ultron this
episode is ross marquand the voice of
red skull now notice the visual of cap's
shield broken in half and his body
strewn alongside those of thor and hulk
as stark is just left to watch it all
this is exactly tony's nightmare vision
cursed into his mind by wanda maximoff
come true and this episode makes it the
fourth one to kill off tony stark really
the only avenger to die on screen in
every repeat appearance on the series
it's almost as if the sky needs to die
for the multiverse to move forward i
actually have a video coming out in a
few days exploring how stark's death may
actually be an absolute point now during
the sequence the watcher's hand swipes
over the frame transitioning it with
this kaleidoscopy texture from the main
mcu reality to this alternate one these
what did happen slides have always had a
storybook aesthetic in past episodes and
now we see why because to the watcher he
is flipping through the pages of what's
essentially a comic book that he's
already read and in his case peering
from one crystalline window into another
thaddeus ross watches in horror as icbms
strike all over the world notice how one
icbm from the texas region if you follow
its trajectory is headed right for
wakanda which ultron must recognize as a
global superpower alongside the us and
russia and china thanos portals into the
aftermath just as he arrived in infinity
war now he already possesses the power
space reality soul and time stones
meaning he must have begun his stone
quest earlier in this universe perhaps
ultron killing thor and or the ancient
one in the nuclear blasts could have
cleared a path for thanos to go to
zandar for the power stone to asgard for
the space stone and so on however gamora
is still alive on the sovereign so he
could not have sacrificed her on vormir
to get the soul stone now gamora could
have sacrificed nebula to get the soul
stone but would she have parted ways
with it without giving her life see
folks when it comes to the infinity
stones this show doesn't really consider
their exact continuity that big a
priority it turns out so we are best
chalking it all up to other universes
the stones are wherever they need to be
for the story to work ultron uses the
mine stone to slice thanos in half on
avengers tower what the hell well i
suppose if you consider that thanos
could have been clouded by his
malthusian ambitions and by comparison
ultron as a super efficient robot brain
could have quickly mastered his stone's
fullest potential to get the draw on
this eco-terrorist who's still figuring
out how his toys work exactly but uh
yeah it is nuts to see ultron wield the
mine stone so perfectly to fillet thanos
and melt a nivelier gauntlet and so
ultron plugs in the five remaining
stones into his new armor wow
there are worlds that needs
me
yeah notice how the stones emit that
heavy
tone the same sound that we heard
thanos's gauntlet would make an infinity
war when emitting stone energy
ultron materializes an army of sentries
using the reality stone but also they
come together in this black ink dot
effect now in comics this is known as
the kirby crackle or the kirby dots
created by artist jack kirby who would
use similar dots to convey cosmic
negative space around energy these kirby
dots return around most of ultron and
the watchers attacks later in this
episode and it elevates ultron to a jack
kirby cosmic level character like
galactus and i love when the show uses
ink in this way like how they showed dr
strange's universe melt back into comic
book style inc the bass elements that
form all of these characters ultron
first destroys asgard i think the
imagery looks a lot like when those
alien battleships strike skyscrapers and
independence day
but if you go through frame bright frame
as asgard explodes notice the water
pouring down from the edges of the disk
before the whole plane obliterates just
like it did when surtur destroyed it and
thor ragnarok then on to the sovereign
which you remember from guardians volume
2 and we see peter quill and gamora and
drax fighting on that same platform that
they fought the abilisk and since this
is in 2015 this is a place they already
would have been to because guardians
volume 2 takes place a month after
guardians volume 1. then we go on to
sakhar where centuries pour into the
grandmasters arena you can see korg
fighting alongside that strainer-headed
gladiator from thor ragnarok who also
cameoed in last week's party thor
episode the grand master dies in the
blast as well and then ego gets hit
looking just as he did in guardians vol
2 the craters on the surface make his
face in a shocked expression with his
mouth gaping open and his eyes widening
oh no i haven't had a chance to bang the
other half of the universe yet and then
onto zandar which of course you saw on
the first guardians during the century
attack the nova corps tower does appear
to be under reconstruction not just
wreckage that ultron has just caused but
apparently some attempts to rebuild from
some past conflict i thought it was just
from ronan's assault in the first
guardians film but at the end of that
movie it was not this much under repair
so we might be looking at the aftermath
of thanos recent attack to steal the
power stone would justify how he got
that stone at least captain marvel
arrives to fight
listen
i've seen the killer robot movie and i
gotta say i really don't think it needs
a sequel yes skynet referring to the
robotic ai computer network that nukes
the planet in the terminator franchise
but this line about the sequel well we
know carol got addicted in 1989 and
returned to earth briefly in 1995 but
then seemed to jet off with the scrolls
she did land in a blockbuster but i
don't think she had enough time to know
that a sequel to the 1984 terminator the
amazing t2 judgment day of 1991 was a
way better film so this killer robot
movie that she was referring to totally
needed its sequel and her wrongness on
this point in my opinion makes her
deserve to lose to ultron here
now ultron was just about to call it
quits it's done
at last
the realization nearly broke the machine
shut up uh the watcher monologuing here
did amount to intervention because had
he said nothing ultron may have
self-destructed or retired and never
thought to move on to the other
universes so the watcher has already
kind of intervened he's gonna have to
intervene to undo his intervention even
after ultron senses him behind his back
the way dr strange did in episode 4 the
watcher continues who said that basking
in the boundless silence of his universe
ultron ascended to a previously
unattainable level of consciousness
he became aware of another he became
aware
of the
i see you yeah this moment of
realization is odd because yeah again we
saw a separate moment of the watcher
first scene ultron infinity at the end
of the party thor episode so when did
the watcher first recognize ultron as a
multiversal threat then or now now here
at new rockstars our sharp wit and keen
eyes can cut through the web of
information out there to give you
top-notch content but to cut through
food you need kamikoto knives kamikoto
makes great japanese steel kitchen
knives using traditional techniques from
japan their knives are used by michelin
star restaurants around the world they
only use premium steel source from mills
in japan and each kamikoto knife is
individually inspected after a 19-step
process which makes them so confident
with their knives that each one comes
with a lifetime guarantee each knife
comes in a beautiful ash wood box that
keeps the knife stored safely and makes
a kamikoto knife a great looking gift
they offer a range of japanese steel
knives from the 13-inch yanagiba that
can slice a full watermelon in half down
to the 5-inch blade better suited for
the smaller fruits and veggies like a
miniature watermelon i grabbed a nakiri
knife and it feels incredible in my hand
it looks really cool it feels well
balanced and super functional it's got
me itching to dice tommy koto has a big
sale going on and is offering our
viewers an extra 50 off any purchase
with discount code new rockstars so head
to kamikoto.com new rockstars well the
watcher does say here i have seen
everything that has ever happened ever
will happen ever could happen and yet
what the hell is this now yes there are
multiple watchers in existence but i
think this one voiced by jeffrey wright
is just the same watcher that we saw at
the end of episode seven and i think
this is his way of describing how he is
just a multiversal being with his
perception divided across an array of
moments in history kind of like he who
remains he's able to see the past
present and future all at once and we
have one set of his eyes reacting to
ultron crashing party thor and another
set of his eyes reacting to ultron here
and that only when ultron responds to
him behind that prism wall despite him
trying to wipe the blind's clothes does
he finally see him as an existential
threat to his script and the
heartbreaking aspect to the story that
the watch at the beginning of the
episode is talking about is literally
ultron breaking the heart of his prism
multiverse that's why this story breaks
his heart more than the others also
notice how much the watcher blinks here
that was a little detail i pointed out
last week as just a bit of evidence of
uwatu's human-like all-ability and now
he blinks like crazy as if trying to
wake up from a dream if a hunger like
that were to be unleashed upon the
multiverse even i cannot imagine the
horrors that might follow yeah the
hunger is also the name given to the
zombie virus in the marvel zombies
comics a virus that spreads across
universes in the pages of the comics
unlike in the show so i'm wondering if
this show could actually follow through
on what the virus is in the comics and
that the watcher could try to use that
multiversal hunger to neutralize this
multiversal hunger clint and natasha
seek a zolophile in a kgb archives
warehouse that clint compares to the
final shot of raiders the lost ark and
the camera tilts up in both versions of
the shot he also later references star
wars the death star plans are not in the
main computer and natasha says hard
copies are harder to steal easier to
destroy but code
code is slippery and it never dies the
lesson they learned from ultron of
course but also one that they will apply
to zola perhaps foretelling how they
might not be able to kill ultron
permanently but rather they have to find
a way to contain him natasha finds the
shield of the red guardian alexis
shostakov from black widow he did not
have that shield in the black widow film
but his action figure did in arnhem
zola's file box there are some other
names in cyrillic letters i didn't take
the time to translate these oh wait of
course i did they seem to be the names
of a bunch of artists who worked on the
what if series there's paula sane he's
the what if production designer then
molly sotak and fran portillo their
design coordinators from marvel studios
then cynthia halley and peter bertucci
those are marvel studios artists and
then in the later shot as natasha thumbs
through these you can see joshua bramley
he's the what if asset supervisor and
then sean something and then el grasso
and then zachary split up into two words
and then may fam maybe my family i'm
just assuming all these are crew or
friends and family these are just the
ones that i spotted ultron breaks into
the watcher's domain i found you i
finally found you in so
many universes so much chaos they need
to be silenced you do not have to do
this yeah the watcher begs using the
same exact words that tony stark did
begging for his life you don't have to
do this which probably gives ultron even
more resolve to bring peace to all of
existence by silencing it natasha and
clint find the same siberian hydra base
from captain america's civil war but
here the tanks that contain the other
winter soldier assassins are now all
empty meaning hydra might have deployed
them to try to stop ultron and obviously
failed the arnhem zola algorithm comes
back on this computer terminal
francis of course similar to how he
greeted steve natasha at camp lehigh and
captain america winter soldier except
now he calls them agents of shield rip
so in addition to zola's ai presence
living on in camp lehigh secretly
corrupting shield as hydra zola was also
present as a backup in the same place
that tony stark realized bucky killed
his parents and cap knew about it
leading to their fight makes me wonder
how maybe in the main mcu zola could
have been a silent partner to zemo and
help supply him that footage as a way to
haunt the avengers from the grave of
hydra and giving one last fu to captain
rogers either way folks zola lives now
they tried to use zola to infiltrate
ultron's code via his sentry hyde mind
the same way that he infiltrated shield
and clint does this by downloading him
in one of his arrows using that same
awesome usb drive arrow that clint used
in the first avengers film and he plugs
it into an ultron sentry with some cool
color coding here zola's ai green
replacing the ultron red go light and
stop light they climb the same silo that
stark chase capped and bucky up in civil
war we see various alternate functions
of clint's arrows like laser netting a
force field barrier and one that just
has a powerful boom boom which might be
what clint is referring to with kate
bishop in the upcoming hawkeye series
this is too dangerous
holy sh
there are arrows more dangerous than
that one natasha catches clint but in a
mirror of natasha's death and end game
clint forces her to let him go actually
in the first avengers film clint dovah
turned back upwards midair to fire
arrows up but here he turns mid-air
downward to face certain death i love
this shot of him falling slow motion in
the swarm of centuries beautiful
composition notice how they tilt the
whole silo at an angle to make clint's
drop look like a deliberate strike and
then they widen out the silo way larger
than it actually is in order to heighten
the contrast of the one versus the many
to give it all a more epic scale natasha
lands from the explosion in the snow
making the pose that yelena made fun of
her for in black widow meanwhile the
watcher and ultron duel and it rules
uwatu withstands a double blast of the
reality stone and the time stone though
note that in this domain which might be
uwatu's version of the mirror dimension
based on how it looks ultron doesn't use
the practical functions of the time
stone of the reality stone like
rewinding the flow of time or like
turning uwati's robes into beetles
they're simply just big energy blasts
and that might be a limitation of the
stones outside of any one reality like
you still remain an all-powerful nexus
god but these specific unique functions
of the stones themselves might not be
exactly usable here now the watcher
defends himself i swore an oath i cannot
exert my will on the natural order of
things i cannot intervene to whom did
the watchers swear this oath in the
comics uatu is one of many watchers the
one assigned to our universe and we know
others existed in the mcu from the
guardians vol 2 scene but we may have to
see uwatu answered to his fellow
watchers for his interference uh blocks
ultron's kirby crackles with a shield of
glowing lines that look like celestial
design like the cosmic energy used by
the eternals the watchers and the
celestials have an antagonistic
relationship in the comics over whether
or not to interfere watchers swear not
to celestials can't help monkeying with
the monkeys but notice how uatu suits up
in this combat armor kind of like the
watcher aeron the renegade from the
comics but the fact that watchers have
armored forms just like the celestials
have these armored forms might be a clue
that these two entities might have been
at war with each other in eon's past
ultron tackles the watcher through these
different worlds we see this pyramid
planet then an ice planet then this
interesting molten lava planet actually
looks a lot like mustafar from star wars
there is a castle in the background that
looks like vader's fortress and come to
think the jungle planet did have some
flora similar to the plant life of
felucia from star wars so the animators
might have worked in some star wars nods
here and then another ice planet and
then this rock planet with floating
columns that a gargantuan ultron bites
down on lumen even larger than the whole
galaxy clearly a nod to galactus
devourer of worlds an entity that we
have been pining to see in the mcu i
think it's the show's way of striking
fear in awe of ultron infinity as a
galacticized threat but even galactus
doesn't consume celestial bodies out of
spite like this he's driven by a
custodial drive to murray condo the
universe of dying dysfunctional planets
then the watcher crashes into times
square with onlookers including that
pineapple shirt guy from vegas in
episode seven there's also a billboard
for olympia the musical as we saw in
times square in episode three but
nothing yet about roger's a musical
because i guess here steve rogers is
taking the oath of office to become the
u.s president something that does happen
in the ultimates comics but perhaps in
this universe steve rogers only ran to
prevent candidate loki from becoming
president that could be how that loki
got pruned to the void ultron's punch
turns times square into wakanda and then
to a medieval castle and then to the
skrull society this could be their
throne world of tarnax iv and then
ending on another frozen planet bringing
uwatu full circle with the snowy
beginnings this episode notice how as
ultron tries to crack the watcher's head
like an egg steam sizzles off of it in
the cold air and this is also the way
captain marvel tried to implode ultron's
head on zandar just showing how with
every fight ultron is learning a new way
to kill someone but the watcher is able
to break free and retreats to his purple
spear where back in episode 4 the
watcher left strange supreme this time
the framing is reversed from their first
encounter uwatu now looks over his
shoulder to see strange creeping up
behind him with all of his monstrous
entities still part of him but of course
you want to has come here because
strange is the one other nexus level
being he might know of who might be able
to help him fight ultron are you ready
to break your oath yeah interesting to
hear strange talk this way as a doctor
bound by his own hippocratic oath to do
no harm but that doesn't apply to robots
i bet the watcher changes his tune i see
now
i need your help
[Music]
yeah notice how the music shifts here
from a dramatic orchestral swell in
choir shrieks to a simple acoustic
guitar melody over the credits it was
the music of dr strange trying to work
past his absolute point episode 4 and
now reflecting this new cooperation
between the two i think we can expect
their solution to be one part using
zola's algorithm to de-link ultron from
his hide mind one part using the hunger
virus and another infinity stone armed
threat and ultimately since ultron
remains a slippery code impossible to
eradicate fully trapping him the way
strange supreme was trapped perhaps by
breaking the multiverse in such a way to
leave it impossible to navigate maybe
what that opening imagery of every
episode showing spiraling broken shards
has been foretelling us this whole time
and of course i think this series is
gonna set up the mcu with a broken
chaotic multiverse ahead of titles like
spider-man no way home and doctor
strange and multiverse madness you can
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter ea boss follow and
subscribe to new rockstars thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]